les premiers extraits de ce livre choc
ont déjà lancé la polémique les
journaliste bob woodward et robert costa
s'apprête à dévoiler un ouvrage intitulé
péril où ils reviennent notamment sur
les dernières semaines de donald trump
au pouvoir selon leurs informations le
chef d'état major marc millet se serait
montré particulièrement inquiet sur de
possibles agissements du président
américain dès le mois d'octobre 2020
soit quelques jours seulement après
l'élection présidentielle le général
aurait appelé son homologue chinois pour
le rassurer quant à d'éventuelles
attaques qui serait décidé par le
commandeur in chief c'est-à-dire par
donald trump generali je veux vous
assurer que le gouvernement américain
est stable et que tout va bien se passer
nous n'allons pas vous attaquer ou
conduire une attaque cinétique contre
vous generali vous et moi nous nous
connaissons depuis maintenant cinq ans
si nous sommes sur le point de vous
attaquer je vous appellerai d'abord ça
ne sera pas une surprise un deuxième
échange téléphonique aurait eu lieu
entre les deux hommes il se serait
déroulé quelques jours seulement après
les événements du 6 janvier dernier au
capitole des événements d'ailleurs qui
aurait semble-t-il poussé mark healey à
tenir et une réunion secrète avec ses
proches conseillers parmi elles les
décisions prises notamment arrêter les
exercices militaires dans la zone indo
pacifique mais surtout et bien revoir
les procédures de l'utilisation de
l'armé nucléaire visiblement soucieux
que donald trump eux d'en face lusage
dans ces derniers jours au pouvoir le
chef d'état major aurait demandé aux
officiers ce qu'ils soient consultés
pour n'importe quelle procédure autour
de ces armes à nucléaire alors ce livre
écrit par des journalistes du washington
post présente sous un aspect a quasi
héroïque les actes du chef d'état-major
mais beaucoup souligne ici aussi à qu'il
pourrait s'agir en fait d'actes de
collusion si ces faits étaient
finalement avérés autre point important
le général miley aurait aussi échanger
avec les responsables de la msa de la
cia ou encore avec la présidente de la
chambre des représentants nancy pelosi
qui est une présidente à démocrate et le
tout dans le dos du président des états
unis des agissements qui pousse certains
aujourd'hui a demandé la démission du
général marque millet en tout cas ce
livre péril qui va paraître le 21
septembre prochain qui aborde aussi les
premiers mois pouvoir de joe biden et
bien il devrait continuer à alimenter
l'actualité ici ainsi que les polémiques
aux états unis